cette année à bordeaux le père noël de
la table s'appelle denis francs 17 sur
20 au gault et millau une étoile au
michelin sud-ouest oblige le chef du
pavillon des boulevards vous propose de
commencer avec une escalope de foie gras
frais de canard poêlé le secret de la
réussite de ce plat tient surtout en
deux points
la qualité du foie et la cuisson l'idéal
c'est d'avoir un poids d'à peu près un
centimètre et demi 1 à 2 cm parce que
trop fin évidemment il faudrait trop
vite à la poêle est trop épais bas ils
seraient pas assez cuit à l'intérieur on
va s'ennuyer de rentrer le fuyard une
minute trente à peut vivre de chaque
côté le temps de l'écouter chanter c'est
très important et ça veut dire est que
déchanter
c'était un plaisir d'écouté
la grande cuisine est toujours un appel
à l'éveil des sens après l'ouïe la vue
accompagnée d'une réduction de vinaigre
de vin d'une compote de pommes d'un jus
de citron confit et de quelques croûtons
de pain d épice ce foie gras poêlé vous
invite à explorer l'opposition sucré
salé entre croquant et fondre leurs
méthodes dans un pool dans un fois très
souple très beau lot on est dans du foie
gras nous sommes dans des choses un
petit peu plus dur la cassante des goût
de noisette côté foie gras dégoût ou
peut-être de châtaignes copé prochain
habituellement on sert le foie gras avec
du vin liquoreux mets préparés de la
sorte on peut très bien dosé un blanc
sec voire même la tendance actuelle est
aussi de faire des repas tout au vin
rouge donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut
choisir un vin rouge assez léger fruité
qui accompagne également le foie frais
mais aussi les poissons et
et peuvent accompagner les carmes façon
au plat de résistance un perdreau coloré
à la poêle puis cuit au four le perdreau
chez denis franc est accompagné de chou
mais du show assaisonné au gingembre
c'est noël pour la note festive quelques
émincé de truies certes le produit est
cher mais 10 à 12 grammes par personne
suffisent
les émincer sont saisis dans un bouillon
de poule à l'huile d'olive avec du poiré
de la fleur de sel
l'objectif est de faire ressortir son
parfum ou maxime robin on a là la
quintessence du parfum en en suivant
cette opération pour finir un dessert
simple comme un jeu d'enfant pour cette
salade tiède de mandarine faire revenir
les quartiers dans un caramel au beurre
demi-sel laisser s'imprégner puis servir
encore tiède accompagné d'un sorbet au
chocolat
les saveurs d'enfance qui seront attirés
autour de minuit le gourmand pernaut